remember what the monster looked like it
were dark it is huge it's more blood
smeared Booker gutted punky with one
claw your specimen - all right gentlemen
cats out of the bag then
GameSpot's game of the Year 2015 is the
wonderful Witcher 3 Wild Hunt Randy what
do you think I think this game is
probably the most coherent world that
I've been in in many years and that's
what for me this is my personal game of
the year as well you know it was a game
that you know I didn't play the previous
witches and I was super impressed with
how easily this game actually caught me
to care about the characters and teach
me about the setting in a very very
quick way so I was immediately engrossed
in what was happening here but made me
curious about everything that made me
feel like I was part of something bigger
and just you know made me actually want
to escape go back to meet bill Barry and
apologize for being an ass
before I change my mind and break your
bones an incredibly impressive
open-world in that it also sort of
forced you to be humble because unlike a
lot of the games we've talked about on
this top five that are open world and
beyond in the top 25 games so many of
them are you are the hero in you gladden
you are all-powerful start where this is
a game in which like the stories in this
game like the quests you encounter even
when you left and made the decisions you
think you're right it's not always you
know rosy by the time you walk away in
this whole yeah so much of that is aided
by a really excellent writing probably
some of the best I've seen in years I
mean there's these convincing characters
you actually kind of learn about you
know you have ciri throughout the game
and I don't want to spoil it for people
11 like finish the game but she becomes
a pretty prominent character later on
despite the fact that you're just
following her most of the game and
throughout the game you're not just
playing things for experience or here
and you're not completing quests just
for the progress yeah doing it just to
see what's gonna happen around the next
corner like what's going on with this
person what do they want to know and how
can I help them what moral choices are
going to come out of this quest the
quests were fun to explore for the
quests sake just to find out what was
gonna happen
yeah the journey itself was more
interesting to me than the destination I
mean now loved seeing how the choices I
made materialize at the end what kind of
conclusions manifested from them but
really it was just really engrossing to
in quests on the side but also the main
quest itself just kind of put you
through really well for 90 something
hours however long I played and I never
got sick of it it's a beautiful looking
world as well I could look fantastic on
PC also held up really well on
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one and then the
size of that world
Randee like here in those spending you
know 30 hours before you might even get
to novigrad and then oh yeah there's
cells Islands off the coast there also
there you can go explore those I
completed this game
20 hours deep it's big I made the rookie
mistake of trying to clear all the
little white scalation marks an opening
area that took me like 12 hours not
realizing that the game was going to
expand even more when you go to the huge
world I just went I just can spend a lot
of time on this game I think it's going
to be something that's gonna consume me
for weeks and it did and it never felt
like it actually dragged at all and just
to your point Danny some of my favorite
moments in this game were actually the
small ones I mean there's a lot of
really epic things that happen in this
game but the ones that stick to me are
the smaller quests and you know some of
the small personal moments that happen
between Jarrell's and the whole cast of
characters that he comes across yeah
fantastic game in a year full of
fantastic games it was hard picking the
top 25 it was certainly difficult
picking the top one but there you have
it our favorite game of 2015 the richer
three Waldo
[Music]